merci dans la discussion générale la
parole est au président Hervé Marseille
pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mais chers collègues avant de commencer
mon propos permettez-moi de saluer son
Excellence madame Emmanuela d'Alessandro
nouvel ambassadrice d'Italie en France
qui nous fait l'honneur de sa présence
dans cette émission à la tribune
présidentielle merci excellence
connu sous le nom de traité du criminal
le traité de coopération bilatérale
renforcée entre l'Italie et la France a
fait l'objet de nombreuses et longues
négociations après une crise
diplomatique et une crise sanitaire il a
finalement été conclu le 26 novembre
dernier au palais du kirinal ce traité
vient sceller une relation dense et
privilégiée une longue amitié entre nos
deux pays comme vous le savez l'italier
la France font partie des pays
fondateurs de la Communauté européenne
du charbon et de l'acier puis de la
Communauté européenne économique depuis
l'origine l'Europe on le voit bien c'est
aussi l'énergie le traité de Rome signé
en 1957 dans la capital italienne et
d'ailleurs une reconnaissance du rôle
essentiel joué par l'Italie dans la
construction du projet européen
nos échanges politiques avec l'Italie
existent depuis longtemps et des sommets
bilatéraux ont été organisés sur
différents sujets pour autant le manque
de cadres et d'habitude dans les
relations diplômes politiques et
administratifs entre nos deux états
expose trop dangereusement les relations
bilatérales aux variations de majorité
tentent en Italie qu'en France la
ratification permettra à nous
représentants respectifs d'exposer sur
la scène internationale européenne des
positions mieux accordées et donc plus
influentes le traité du kirinal
s'inscrit dans l'esprit du traité de
l'Elysée de 1963 celui-ci avait posé les
jalons du couple franco-allemand et
donner une base solide à une coopération
régulière il a aussi impulsé un dialogue
systématique entre l'Allemagne et la
France la France et l'Italie ont 515 km
de frontières communes et partagent à la
fois des espaces naturels des
infrastructures et des bassins de vie
les enjeux de cet espace frontalier sont
donc multiples sécurité environnement
économique ou encore liés aux transports
de voyageurs et de marchandise le traité
du kirinal a un objectif simple
organiser la relation bilatérale en lui
donnant un cadre et des orientations
stratégiques qui permettront de
l'inscrire dans la durée les
négociations entamées depuis 2018 avait
alors montré la grande proximité de nos
deux gouvernements et notre convergence
sur de nombreux objectifs notamment
européens je souhaite rappeler ici
quelques propositions essentielles et
concrètes que promule traité une
politique étrangère ayant vocation à
stabiliser et préserver la mer
Méditerranée occidentale et orientale
ainsi qu'une meilleure concertation de
nos pays pour la défense de position
commune au sein de l'OTAN et de l'Union
européenne une politique de défense qui
instaure une collaboration stratégique
étroite et de haut niveau avec une
assistance mutuelle en cas d'agression
sur le territoire de l'un d'entre eux
une politique de sécurité à travers la
création d'une unité opérationnelle
franco-italienne dont l'ambition est de
mieux coordonner les actions contre les
réseaux d'immigration clandestine la
criminalité la corruption et la fraude
s'agissant de l'immigration je vous
rappelle combien dans ce domaine
l'Italie a souvent été abandonné à
elle-même et combien il faut accompagner
les efforts dans ce sens une politique
agricole qui privilégie et protège la
qualité des produits les AOP et les IGP
l'instauration d'un service civil commun
pour les jeunes il prévoit l'invitation
régulière de ministre au Conseil des
ministres respectifs sur le modèle du
traité d'Aix de la chapelle le traité
assure également un volet parlementaire
en reconnaissant l'importance de la
coopération entre nos parlements
respectifs et je vous remercie madame la
ministre de l'avoir souligné dans votre
propos ainsi mon collègue bouché le 25
septembre dernier les Italiens ont
choisi de placer à la tête de leur pays
madame Meloni madame Meloni avait alors
déclaré à propos du Traité du kirinal
que c'était un acte qui n'était pas
démocratique car le Parlement italien
n'avait pas été consulté et qu'il
servait avant tout les intérêts français
elle avait même dénoncé un impérialisme
français
et lors de l'examen de la ratification
au Sénat italien le rapporteur la cité
le parti Fratelli d'Italia et ses alliés
ont voté contre la ratification du
traité où ce sont abstenus on considéra
qu'il s'agit de péripéties de campagne
même si ils sont préoccupants cette
position peut faire naître des doutes
sur la mise en œuvre de l'application du
traité pour autant des signes
encourageants et des clarifications ont
été données depuis ainsi hier lors de sa
déclaration de politique générale la
présidente du Conseil italien rappelait
à dessin que l'Italie faisait pleinement
partie de l'Europe et qu'elle souhaitait
une intégration européenne plus efficace
madame la ministre le président de la
République a pu rencontrer Madame mélony
lors de son déplacement en Italie le
week-end dernier et je considère que
c'est une bonne chose le sujet a été
bien évoqué dans leurs échanges j'espère
que vous pourrez nous apporter des
éclaircissements dans ce domaine est-ce
que la mise en œuvre du traité est bien
l'ordre du jour des agendas politiques
perspectif peut-être pourrez-vous nous
éclairer sur cet aspect des choses vous
avez compris que le groupe Union
centriste appelle de ses vœux toute
action en ce sens alors où les
équilibres mondiaux sont bouleversés que
la guerre a fait son retour sur le sol
européen il est plus que nécessaire de
scaler durablement entre la France et
l'Italie une coopération historique et
des ambitions communes l'impulsion
décisive du gouvernement de Monsieur
Draghi et le précieux concours du
président matarella ont abouti au Traité
du Quirinal qui ne doit pas être ralenti
pour le bien de l'Europe à laquelle les
deux pays travaillent depuis longtemps
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
le groupe Union centriste bien sûr votre
a favorablement à la ratification de ce
traité et je vous en remercie
[Applaudissements]